this video was made possible by tab for
a cause raise money for charity just by
opening tabs which you were going to do
anyway
link in the description the Muller
report is finally out and in it Mr
Muller created a one-way street that
could not have found the president
committed a crime but it could have
found him innocent and unless you
understand this legal framework you
won't understand them all a report at
all
[Music]
hey legal eagles today we are talking
about the Muller report I'm going to try
to explain the legal framework that
Muller and his team created and based
their conclusions on because frankly it
colors absolutely everything in the
report itself Muller starts the report
by setting some legal ground rules this
decision changes the course of the
entire investigation Muller starts by
noting that there is an office of legal
counsel or OLC opinion and a DOJ policy
not to indict a sitting president in
fact I covered this entire issue on a
video about whether a sitting president
can in fact be indicted based on current
Supreme Court precedent which I'll
linked down below
Muller's view is not an unreasonable one
this very issue has never been tested by
the Supreme Court and there are in fact
contrary OLC opinions and differing
views on the constitutional limits of
indicted a sitting president so starting
with the premise that a president cannot
in fact be indicted by the Department of
Justice Muller says that his hands are
tied because of quote fairness concerns
specifically Muller says that the power
of the government to accuse someone of
committing a crime has to be balanced by
constitutional protections including the
right of the accused to a quote neutral
adjudicatory forum so that the accused
if they are in fact accused of a crime
by the government can clear their name
now it is absolutely 100% true that
things like due process a right to a
speedy trial right to a jury a right to
face your accusers it's all incredibly
important and enshrined in the
Constitution and the Bill of Rights but
because Muller accepts that he cannot
indict the President and put the
president through a formal trial the
president would not have those
protections in other words the
would not be able to potentially clear
his name through a trial and the other
mechanisms that we normally give to the
accused so given those two premises that
because mr. Muller cannot indict the
president and because the president
cannot clear his name that it would be
wrong to come to a formal conclusion
that the president broke the law Muller
notes that these considerations
disappear when the president is not in
office because when the president leaves
office he is available to be accused and
indicted of any crimes that he may have
committed in other words Muller is
leaving it to Congress to impeach for
the president to resign or for the
president simply to leave office for the
normal mechanisms of the judicial
process to kick in on the other hand
because the same fairness concerns don't
exist with respect to finding someone
innocent in other words no one is going
to dispute the fact that you have found
them innocent and try and challenge that
finding mr. Muller finds that he can
come to the conclusion that the
president was innocent or that the
evidence did not amount to an indictable
offense so based on the rules that
Muller set up there was no way that mr.
Muller could have found president from
committed any crime this is a standard
that does not exist anywhere else in
criminal law or frankly in politics now
that's not to say that this standard is
wrong or was improper this is a standard
that may have to exist based on the
idiosyncrasies of the executive branch
and the interplay between the separation
of powers between the President and
Congress but at the end of the day mr.
Muller created a one-way street the
Muller investigation could have found
the president innocent but it could not
ever have found him guilty as one of you
legal eagles pointed out on Twitter so
in oversimplified terms they were
allowed to rule not guilty or not not
guilty and they ruled not not guilty and
that's basically right Mahler states in
the report that quote based on facts and
applicable legal standards we are unable
to reach that judgment that judgment
being that the president is innocent
so given this legal framework we might
ask what's the point of the Muller
investigation then Muller decided
to tie his hands in the first instance I
don't know if in fact this is
constitutionally mandated I don't think
anyone does it's never been tested at
the Supreme Court but it's a very safe
position it puts the ball in the court
of the political institutions namely
Congress and the judiciary and it's hard
to argue that in a world where
institutions are being eroded norms are
being destroyed and powers are simply
being claimed by various parts of the
government by Fiat that this isn't a
good decision on a political level
Muller is clearly putting the ball in
the court of Congress and by proxy the
American people to make the decision on
this particular case on the other hand a
lot of people are going to look at this
decision and call it an abdication of
the power that was specifically
delegated to the Special Counsel that we
created these rules in the wake of
Watergate and eventually the Clinton
impeachment hearings specifically to
deal with these types of cases that are
the hard cases and if it's not the
special prosecutor that's going to deal
with them then then who is these are
difficult questions and those are
reasonable positions to take on both
sides but according to mr. Muller
himself because the investigation
definitively could not conclude that the
President of the United States
obstructed justice and colluded the
purpose of the investigation was to
quote preserve evidence when memories
were fresh and documentary materials
were available
so effectively Muller viewed his
investigation as one to gather the
evidence to preserve it and to give it
to the powers that are going to be
responsible for actually making a
decision now I want to be careful here I
don't view the Muller report as an
impeachment referral as some people have
suggested mr. Muller clearly
contemplates and even states that
Congress has an oversight role of the
executive and in fact Muller states that
Congress can punish the president for
his actions that is in fact one of its
constitutional duties so for better
worse I think
that we can view mr. Muller as the
quintessential institutionalist
and we can view the Muller report as the
safest institutional play that the
special counsel could have issued so
given that this was an evidence
gathering mission let's examine the
evidentiary findings in a prior video
about the bar summary of the Mullen
report I asked the question about
whether this was a case where there was
in fact no evidence or whether this was
the case where there was a lot of
evidence but not enough to meet the
beyond-a-reasonable-doubt standard well
this report is worse than that with
respect to collusion and conspiracy the
Mulder report finds that there was
actually quite a lot of evidence
including a string of incredibly damning
situations but looking at that
holistically it wasn't enough to be able
to charge the president with the crime
of conspiracy to collude with the
Russians as that is defined in the
Muller report however with respect to
obstruction of justice it's a whole
different ballgame
the Mullen report finds numerous places
where Mr Muller probably found
obstruction beyond a reasonable doubt
for example in one passage Muller says
quote our investigation found multiple
acts by the president that were capable
of exerting undue influence over law
enforcement investigations carried out
through one-on-one meetings in which he
sought to use his official power outside
of his usual channels and in other
places mr. Muller found quote
substantial evidence of obstruction of
justice and in one of the most damning
passages mr. Muller states that the
president's efforts to influence the
investigation were mostly unsuccessful
but that is largely because the persons
who surrounded the president declined to
carry out his orders or accede to his
requests it's hard to read these
sections and not come to the conclusion
that mr. Muller thought president Trump
committed obstruction of justice but
only refrained from saying so based on
the legal framework that he created at
the start of this investigation because
obstruction of justice includes not only
obstruction itself but attempted
obstruction in the same way that firing
a gun at someone is attempted murder
even if the bullet is defective and
doesn't in fact fire mr. Muller lays out
10 in
senses a possible obstruction analyzes
them and mostly comes to the conclusion
that given those facts and the relevant
law that the situations can give rise to
obstruction of justice here in this
visual representation we can see one
commentator color-coded all of the
different elements of obstruction and
compared that to the ten instances of
potential obstruction by the Trump
administration and you can see that most
of the elements are met for most of the
potential instances but at the same time
mr. Muller does not give a standard by
which we can measure his conclusions for
example mr. Muller does not say that we
are certain beyond a reasonable doubt
that this is an overt act as required by
obstruction of justice or we are certain
beyond a reasonable doubt that the
president had the corrupt motive
required for obstruction of justice
but remember based on the rules that he
created he could not come to that
conclusion
instead he leaves it to Congress and to
us if this video leaves you wanting to
make some positive change in this world
you're not alone
I'd recommend tab for a cause which lets
you raise money for the charity of your
choice just by opening up new tabs in
your browser tab for a cause is a Google
Chrome extension that allows you to pick
a charity and then every time you open
up a new tab instead of it being blank
it displays a couple of ads and the
money you generate is donated to your
charity there is no charge to you and it
actually does some good for this world
tab for a caused users have raised
hundreds of thousands of dollars for
charity it is the easiest possible way
to do some good in this world so click
on the link in the description to
download the extension and do some good
by doing what you were going to do
anyway surfing the internet do you agree
with mr. Miller's framework do you agree
with my analysis leave your objections
in the comments and check out my other
real law reviews over here where I talk
about whether a sitting president can be
indicted in a bunch of other topics
where I'll see you in court